good morning John so remember a couple
of years ago when I had a baby oh great
I was really excited cuz I got to
officially tell Dad jokes is a real life
dad and now some something amazing has
happened and uh Oren is now 2 years old
barely and he is now telling jokes I
have to share them like my dad jokes
video had a lot of jokes in it
unfortunately Oren has not told that
many jokes he is told for and so I would
like to share with you every joke my
two-year-old son has ever told in order
let's start with his very first joke it
went something like this
mama daddy mom da imagine that but I'm a
two-year-old it was a little weird the
weird thing is that like I also think
that's funny and I feel like I think
it's funny for the same reason he does
which is very weird considering that he
only recently started like existing joke
number two and a little something like
this
blue baby so upon realizing that one
word could modify another word he's
getting a grip on adjectives he starts
to apply adjectives to things that those
adjectives don't apply to and he thinks
that's very funny this was followed by
others in the genre that I consider
basically the same joke so not separate
jokes like blue moon and also police bus
which is you know he doesn't know this
but like blue moons do exist for us like
as a metaphorical thing and police buses
exists also literal joke number three
they're coming faster now John this was
very recently he pointed to his we put
some corduroy pants on him and he
pointed to his pants and he said Papa
pants Papa being his grandfather our dad
who yes where that's a corduroy pants so
as far as I can tell Orin is now making
fun of our dads fashion advice which as
far as I'm concerned top notch and
finally also earlier this week I'm
looking at pictures with Oren of himself
he's looking at pictures of himself and
I say who's who is that and he says baby
which is often what he says and I said
but which baby is it and he says cocoa
nut
which everybody agreed was a very good
joke John it's Black Friday it's the day
in America in which we realize that
there are no holiday is left until
Christmas and thus we all have to be
saddled with the collective burden of
being societally responsible for the
acquisition and giving of items to
people that we love which is stressful
it is also the time at which retailers
offer outrageous savings and deals and
etcetera and when cards against
humanity' does this I don't know what it
is I recorded this last night so I don't
know but it's something weird but maybe
we can make your Black Friday shopping
easier I'll start out with this book of
poetry that a bunch of nerdfighters
worked on together to create all
proceeds will go to the foundation to
decrease worldsuck but also this Friday
and through the weekend dftba.com isn't
just celebrating Black Friday we're
celebrating ten years of being a company
with free shipping for every order of
$50 and over so if you want something
McElroy brothers at the Gregory Brothers
have their green brothers I think that's
all that brothers or Slipgate or Lindsay
Ellis the valley folk tons of other
creators come on by the first 1,000
items bought on Black Friday and on will
get this token of our appreciation like
a challenge coin thing that says don't
forget to be awesome on it also pod
counts having a special today and this
weekend for people who want to buy
tickets as gifts tickets aren't
discounted but you will get an I like
podcasts pin delivered to you in the
mail before Christmas as long as you
live in the u.s. dftba is also stopping
the sock Club and the pin Club and
instead we have a new thing the flare
Club a quarterly box that increases the
amount of stuff you get per thing and
decreases how much we're paying for
shipping it's 30 dollars a quarter and
we're stuffing each of them fill a bunch
of surprise goodness you could check out
what's in the first box at dftba.com
right now and also right after Apple
with this video I'm going over to the
dftba warehouse to do a live stream on
Hanks channel while we're packing up
your packages so come on over if you
want to hang out there John I'll see you
on Tuesday